something is happening in Texas
since 2021 there have been 31 separate
lawsuits in federal district courthouses
all over the state in which Texas has
sued the federal government
let's look at just one in Amarillo about
immigration the judge in this case there
was no jury ruled that the Biden
administration had to continue a trump
policy called remain in Mexico that
keeps Asylum Seekers out of the country
the Biden Administration eventually got
that decision reversed but it took
almost a whole year and as they waited
for the Supreme Court to do that they
also had to obey the decision and keep
Asylum Seekers out of the country
all because of this one judge's ruling
and in fact the Texas Attorney General's
office which filed the case had sought
this judge out specifically
and over the next two years they would
bring in cases against the federal
government again and again and again
he's not alone Texas has gone back to
this judge again and again too
you're not supposed to be able to pick
which judge hears your case but in Texas
you can it's called judge shopping it's
only possible in a place like Texas and
it's helped make Texas into a powerful
weapon for changing how things work
everywhere in the country
[Music]
each state in the U.S has at least one
Federal District Court Texas has four
they're the bottom level of the federal
court system federal courts mostly hear
cases involving National laws and
federal judges are appointed by the
president there are over 600 District
judges across all of these courts so
several judges in each court and usually
the judge who hears your case is chosen
randomly Randomness is a critical
principle because the idea is that the
judicial system is supposed to be on the
whole a neutral Arbiter of legal
disputes but the US is Big there are a
lot of big States and even when a state
has multiple federal court districts
some of those districts are still really
big like this one the Northern District
of Texas
if you're in Lubbock and your case gets
randomly assigned to a judge in Dallas
five hour drive to get to court so
partly to solve for that many districts
are further subdivided into multiple
divisions and each usually has its own
Courthouse but different districts have
different rules for which case goes to
which division for example over in the
central district of California there are
three divisions with clear rules meant
to make sure the cases stay local but in
the Northern District of Texas those
rules aren't so strict it's much easier
to file a case in whatever division you
choose same with the other Texas
districts here's where that becomes a
problem
the southern district of Texas has 28
judges for seven divisions but for most
of the last two years two of those
divisions have had just one active judge
each here in the Victoria division
that's been judged Drew Tipton and in
the Galveston division it's judge
Jeffrey Brown and this happens all over
the state in the Northern District this
judge Matthew kizmarek is the only judge
in the Amarillo Division and judge Reed
O'Connor is the only one for the Wichita
Falls division
and that means that if you choose to
file your lawsuit in one of those places
you know who the judge will be
so you get a situation where over two
years the Texas Attorney General files
eight separate lawsuits against the
Biden Administration in Victoria because
they knew judge Tipton would hear them
cases about the border wall the minimum
wage gun laws judge Tipton had sided
with the state of Texas had embraced a
pretty broad view of why Texas could sue
in the first place and had issued
Nationwide injunctions barring the Biden
Administration from carrying out its
policies so yeah I mean I don't think
there was much of a mystery about why
they would choose judge Tipton the
second thing that makes Texas unique is
where it sits in this chart
if the losing side of a district judge's
decision appeals it goes up to one of
the 12 appeals courts also called the
circuit courts a decision appealed from
there goes up to the Supreme Court and
all Texas district courts report up to
the fifth Circuit Court which with a big
majority of judges appointed by
Republican presidents is the most
notoriously conservative of all the
circuit courts and broadly speaking very
likely to agree with even the most
conservative rulings we saw this when a
private group filed a lawsuit in
Amarillo seeking to ban abortion pills
that had been legal for 20 years
in April 2023 judge kazmarek sided with
the private group saying the U.S Food
and Drug Administration had to roll back
its approval of miffipristone for the
whole country the fifth Circuit Court
largely agreed and the case made it to
the Supreme Court which then actually
paused that decision but you know at
multiple points we were hours away from
this really shockingly Broad and
remarkable rule in that would have
dramatically restricted access to
Memphis Princeton on a nationwide basis
going into effect and so you know I
think the notion that like hey we walked
up to the cliff but didn't fall in
um doesn't mean everything's okay but
while the Supreme Court moved quickly to
pause the Memphis decision often it
actually just sits on cases for months
before it hears them effectively
allowing the lower court judge's
decision to dictate federal law during
that time
like in 2022 when judge Tipton ruled
that Biden couldn't reprioritize which
undocumented immigrants to deport first
almost a year later we're still waiting
for the Supreme Court to rule on that
and Tipton's ruling is still in effect
any good lawyer is going to try to
maximize the chances that their clients
going to win what's different about
what's been happening lately is
naturally trying to stack the deck so
that you're guaranteed of a specific
outcome judge shopping the way we see it
today is a relatively new phenomenon
so how do we fix it well the district
courts themselves could decide to do
things differently in February the
southern district of Texas changed
Victoria's single judge status it now
has two active judges and since these
are federal courts Congress could also
pass a law regulating the way cases are
distributed
there's a Bill in Congress right now
that would redirect any lawsuit that
wants to block a federal policy to the
courts in Washington D.C
or the Supreme Court could write new
rules for the lower courts
but until then anyone who wants a good
shot at getting a case before The
Supreme Court knows that in Texas
district courts
you can pick your judge
[Music]
foreign